let's start with this I fully fully 100
thousand percent with no hedge do not
believe that you can teach
entrepreneurship in the Entrepreneurship
everybody in America everybody watching
this right now it's the American thing
to believe people don't think of
entrepreneurship as a skill right they
don't think they can be LeBron or be you
know Nine Inch Nails or be fitter ascent
but everybody looks at me and says I can
do that yeah they don't understand that
it's a talent you may have
entrepreneurial tendencies you may have
aspiration to be an entrepreneur it's
more practical to actually recognize I'm
a talent and let's say they think of a
hundred I'm the best yeah then being a
68 is actually quite financially and
Happiness worthy whereas if you look at
the Brawn and he's a hundred being a 68
means that like you'll spend a lot of
time in rec leagues like like it's
there's a different right crush it is
it's to find don't work for me go home
and make 10 to $15,000 a year more
chopping up basketball content cuz you
love it so much if you think that that's
the thing you want in your life the
thing that most people realize which is
true it's just like it cool but I can
you know make 150 thousand this way and
then you know it's just I think
everybody lies to themselves
you have to audit who you actually are
it costs you money to try to be a 68
musician you pay 15,000 demo you have an
overhead like you can't pay rent this
thing being a 60 even for the people
that are clearly understanding that
they're not many talent wise it's
actually quite practical to be a 68 so
that's it that's what I got so thanks
for having me